hello and welcome I'm Peter but you all
probably know me better as Peter why
mile from my YouTube channel and today
we are going to take a look at the
character welcome Leung welcome Lum is a
well balanced but strong character who
excels at block punishing with his long
limbs and pressuring opponents with his
vast toolkit of strings his playstyle is
quite flexible as he can play more
defensively because of his great ability
to whiff punished as well as block
punished or he can be played offensively
because of his string based mix-ups
however he can be a little lackluster
when it comes to his lows besides his
down back for being +5 on hit and
forcing Crouch all the rest of his lows
are - on hit and are quite launched
punishable
if blocked but where Falcom LOM really
shines is where he has his opponent
against the wall here he has access to
his devastating guard breaking walls
flatting charge up moves that can catch
opponents off guard
now let's took a look at some of his
best moves to use as well as combos and
setups
take it away Ocho
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright alright so now you have an idea
of how to play [ __ ] one but what is
this true potential look like and what
can he do in a real match well I'm glad
you asked
check out these [ __ ] Lomb highlight
plays submitted to chotto TV from the
past week enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
please tell me thank you Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up next these are the pros you can learn
more about FACA mom from you can check
out their streams and YouTube channels
in the description below make sure to
leave them a like comment subscribe and
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I believe
[Music]
[Music]
all righty guys thank you all so much
for taking the time to watch this video
be sure to hit like and subscribe give
this Manno chotto your love and support
if you enjoy any of this content
whatsoever be sure to check out my
channel as well it's peter y mal and
it's in the video description below as
well I would like to give a huge shout
out and thank you for watch out for
reaching out to me to do this
collaboration it was an absolute
pleasure and I'd love to do it again
sometime in the future peace out guys
see you next time
[Music]